bonjour matteo ghisalberti merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
peut-on parler de mauvaise gestion de
l'épidémie de kovy 19 par giuseppe
comptait en tout cas c'est la justice
qui le dira mais il ya beaucoup
d'éléments qui laisse penser que le
gouvernement italien a pris des mesures
trop tardivement pour à juguler
l'épidémie
alors qu'il avait déjà agi dans certains
zones de la même région lombardie dans
laquelle se trouve aussi bergame et même
pas de finir on se souviendra des villes
de codognan et et d'autre onze communes
autour de cette localité qui avait été
fermé en cercle et vraiment on parlait
même par les forces de l'ordre
et bien comme l'a dit votre reportage
effectivement on voit qu'il y a il
renvoie la balle entre le gouvernement
et la région
laubach 10 mai scène
comment dire c'est une guerre surtout
politique parce que le gouvernement et
soutenue par des forces de centre gauche
la région lombardie par des forces de
centre-droite en particulier par la
ligue de matteo salvini qui est
considéré comme une menace par les
gouvernements mais aussi par apparemment
la présidence de la république parce que
d'ici quelques 2000 vende on devra aussi
renouveler le président de la république
allait si on allait voter maintenant des
fort probable que le gouvernement qui
votera le prochain kibira le prochain
précédent la république elle pourrait
avoir une majorité différente favorable
à la vie de matteo salvini
vous parliez à l'instant de la situation
en lombardie à une région a forcément
qui a été très touché 1 lors de cette
crise du coronavirus on ampute à
giuseppe compter la responsabilité d'un
retard dans la création d'une zone rouge
en lombardie
en quoi ce retard at il été déterminant
dans la propagation du virus
écoutez moi je suis originaire de
bergame d'ailleurs donc j'ai un peu vu à
travers les témoignages de ma famille et
de mes proches
l'évolution de cette gestion de la crise
et par exemple le gouvernement a fait
arriver dans une autre commune de notre
présence
l'armée pour être prêt à éventuellement
un cercle et à enfermer les communes de
nero était alsa naulleau mme bardot
mais finalement cette troupe sont restés
dans la tente et ils n'ont pas agi parce
que finalement après le gouvernement a
d'abord un situé créer la zone rouge
concernant la lombardie et aux autres
provinces italiennes et quelques jours
après tout la zone rouge sur le pays
entier donc on a eu effectivement une
conduira en panne avant et deux pas en
arrière de la part du gouvernement parce
que si la déplacer l'armée c'est à dire
qu'il fallait faire quelque chose et
qu'il était conscient de la nécessité
d'agir mais finalement il n'a pas fait
et il ne faut pas oublier aussi que
jusqu'à quelques jours avant la
fermeture de la lombardie les maires de
plusieurs villes de cette région
notamment celui des bergame invité la
population à sortir faire comme si rien
n'était alors qu' il y avait déjà
clairement une menace qu'on connaissait
parce que l'audi qu'il existe à l'audi
et coloniaux qui dit ça à 100 km à peu
près de bergame avait été déjà touché
fortement par cette maladie on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans notre reportage
plusieurs familles italiennes
endeuillées ont ont porté plainte
vous comprenez ces familles qui
attendent des réponses de la part de la
justice
oui complètement parce que comme je dis
tout à l'heure il gouvernement à
appliquer des schémas de confrontation
politique pour gérer cette crise qui
était
une crise sanitaire est une menace pour
le pays entier
donc il n'a pas voulu comme on ira
passer maître d'un côté les la
confrontation politique les rivalités
politiques avec les autres partis qui
sont naturelles dans une démocratie n'y
a rien à dire
mais dans ce cas il aurait fallu
peut-être s'est serré les coudes et 10
rebonds mais d'à côté nos différents
pendant la gestion de cette crise et
tout le monde participe parce que tous
ou attaquer d'ailleurs le virus a
contaminé les premiers les premières
semaines de l'urgence des représentants
de politiques de la majorité de
l'opposition parce qu'ils te regarde et
il avait pas de couleur politique le
grife donc ça aurait été intéressant de
travailler ensemble et peut-être on
aurait pu éviter davantage de morts faut
pas oublier que les les hôpitaux de la
lombardie ont été vraiment mis sous une
tension exceptionnel et on aurait pu
peut-être la limite est tout simplement
en faisant soigner les personnes chez
elles déjà les moins graves
un peu comme on aurait peut-être pu
faire aussi à parier plutôt qu'un mot qu
éviter d'engorger les services des
urgences alors je vous ai fait compter
affirme ne pas être inquiète quant à sa
convocation devant la justice
aurait-il des raisons de l'être et que
risque-t-il concrètement vous savez il y
a aussi un problème d'image parce que
monsieur comptait un train de lancer les
états généraux qui on n'a pas vraiment
compris de quoi il s'agit de naissance
que ça devrait être un afin de vous
et que tous les représentants politiques
pour relancer le pays et l'économie
italien qui va très très mal il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui risquent de se
retrouver sous le seuil de pauvreté dans
des conditions de misère mais
le fait d'être et dallas avoir la
possibilité d'être de se retrouver sous
une enquête judiciaire
alors que on essaye de relancer les pays
elle va peser très lourd sur sa
popularité qui était déjà en chute libre
on l'a vu aussi justement après cette
conférence de presse que des italiens
l'ont hué et ils nous ont demandé de
donner de l'argent aux gens et de ne pas
faire les intérêts de l'europe donc
mais ce côté aussi joue sa carrière
politique parce qu'il n'a pas un parti
pour le moment il n'est pas élu
donc on pourrait tout simplement se
passer de lui et à avoir un autre
précédent du conseil des ministres si
une autre majorité se forme dans le
parlement ou bien si on va voter
merci matteo ghisalberti d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de putsch médias merci beaucoup